so what are we gonna be doing today well
today we're gonna be doing a little bit
of electric stim on our gentleman right
here we're gonna use it to simulate and
mimic labor pains basically since the
try guys became a thing doing the pain
simulator has been our number one most
requested activity so we're
electrocuting ourselves I'm actually
electrocuting you but yes childbirth
simulator which is gonna make my muscles
contract to say muscles this is whew
there do you think we'll die I've gotten
hurt
lots of times so how painful can this be
it is the most painful thing in the
world I don't think there's any external
pain in my opinion that could simulate
the way labor feels the closest we could
get is to get babies shut them up our
asses and poop them out as they
electrocute us labor is terrible depends
on who you are so I had a 14-hour labor
but my sister had a two-hour labor I
want that one once we can't handle any
more pain our safe word is epidural
childbirth is so painful that you would
gladly have a needle stuck between the
two vertebrae in your back so where are
we going to be putting our electrodes
take your rectus muscles will feel tight
on your abdomen I'm so nervous and I'm
sure I'm gonna fight I do for okay what
did you bring a razor no you're putting
double the amount a little stickies on
me we're having twins
this will mimic a lot because it'll
actually make the whole abdominal region
contract in real childbirth it's your
full torso it's your stomach and it's
your back so we're gonna be putting it
on my back as well a lot of women tear
how much actually tears during it I
could tear all the way to your rectum
like tear open you just have one big
hole crack have you electrocute anyone's
taint before no I'm gonna do back
stomach and could show me your tape my
phantom vagina just a really commit
what a woman might feel you may not know
this but a great many women poop on the
delivery table because the act of
pushing is very much like having a bowel
movement what is the likelihood that the
muscle contractions to force us to that
will depend on where you put the
electrodes yeah I'd rather haven't
you're my butthole
there then you're my babies thank you
for going first by the way I hate this
I'm gonna turn it on just enough for you
to get used of the sensation of glue it
stings that is not the worst pain in the
world but it's not pleasant the suspense
is killing me okay yeah there's the
tango one two three four five it's just
like my entire belly is vibrating I'm
not ready for this that's the front oh I
feel it in the back now I think we
should do this guy just let's see what
you feel he's shaking right now my god
it's like a million ants and needles
just crawling through my skin you need
to get your body and your self mentally
ready to deal with all of that pain and
once active labor kicks in then you
scream are you ready
excuse my hand oh my god
[Applause]
oh that hurts alive that's like somebody
just digging their nails into your
stomach
holy [ __ ] I'm sweating right now it
would be really nice to have my spouse
here supporting me
what a terrible alarm that it's baby
time what a painful reminder of the next
12 hours of pain you're going to endure
the attractions at that point are two to
three minutes apart or even closer 1 to
2 minutes apart very intense and I felt
like it was like a vise grip inside my
belly that would tighten and then
release it it's getting worse each time
oh that's an epidural okay I give up my
wives give up I can't focus on doing
anything when it's happening good great
man you did great did we have it or did
I just opt out and we're not having the
child when you have a vaginal birth that
baby does not come out in one push and
you're just laying there and I remember
it very clearly laying there in the
delivery room looking at the ceiling and
thinking her head is sticking out at my
vagina we're gonna simulate a longer
contraction no you're okay we're gonna
do some on the back where there's not
hair here comes the contraction
contraction contraction
[Applause]
the back is like the most painful that I
can't even explain the feeling my wife
had an emergency c-section or the first
child so I'm behind a car to my wife and
the doctors are doing their thing behind
the curtain they said wait until we give
you the cue to stand up I thought I
heard the cue so I stood up and I looked
and what I saw was my wife's abdomen you
know cut open and clamped back and on a
table next to where they taken out her
intestines and her liver and all the
support in bowls they take out the stuff
that's locking the baby I step back down
my wife said is everything okay I just
nodded but I wanted to say what the feel
like feels like it's simultaneously
cooling my [ __ ] and my balls closer
together and ripping it apart okay one
of the worst things I felt why am I
waiting for the epidural when I could
just wake up and then there's my baby
are you ready this baby is coming
whether I
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Music]
and then the next push at she came and I
felt her kicking me in the thighs and
her little arms and I immediately
started crying because I was like this
is my baby I love my mom I'm sorry I did
this to her if your mom is the toughest
person in the universe I don't care who
you are your mom is tougher than you a
lot of it's not fun but they'll love you
have for your child is indescribable you
love your kids so much your wife would
be proud I have a small equaling of how
painful this is
sweetie we'll be there for you now when
I see women I'm just gonna say I am so
sorry that people ever think that they
can tell you what to do with your body
because you have to deal with your own
body already and it wants to kill me
here delivery is tough it's very hard
it's painful but once the baby out it's
magical
don't think it's worth it I do think
it's worth it it's the greatest thing in
the world I mean that's a really special
feeling to know that someone went
through all of that to create you I feel
like I have to call my mom and just
thank her she already pushed me out of
her had to raise me for 18 years I don't
think she wants to hear me